there are three basic skills we need to
be on work with fractions and to do
everything else that's related to
fractions okay the three basic skills
are couple of your question one and two
it's just simplifying okay maybe I
should practice simplifying that's one
in suit now I think we're pretty good at
that
okay so we'll get through that very
quickly question three sawed off
question four and five have a look at
them with me question four and five on
page 18 what's being asked no bad luck
for you I've got good aim even if you're
sitting in the back now as you've all
been saying you've got two kinds of
fractions there in questions four and
five you have mixed fractions or mixed
numerous okay problem and improper right
so therefore we need to be able to not
just simplify these fractions by convert
between them now the last basic idea
which is really about questions seeks is
kind of an extension of both of these
which is doing operations doing
operations between all these different
kinds of fractions so I've got my
whiteboard markers here you know and my
aim hasn't gotten any worse
that's a terrible throat okay let's uh
let's quickly go through soon because I
think you guys will be fine with that
let's do let's do one a together okay
now what's the idea but line I'm
simplified or you can see the other used
a word for that is I'm reducing okay
well the fraction they give us a six
eight so it's three or four but how do
we get that what am I looking for
you're almost there I'm gonna have both
numbers which will give me three and
four that's right you can't always have
them sometimes so I'm looking for I'm
looking for what we call my highest
common factor all right okay you think
you're on the right track
and our highest common factor is the
biggest number that will divide into
both us which in this case is two so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna put some work in here
you don't have to but it makes clear
what's going on and later on when you
come back to this unit like oh this is
where the numbers came from okay as as
we could suggest it I'm gonna divide the
top and the bottom by two like that see
if I do it to the top and the bottom
it's it's all okay I haven't actually
changed the number it's still the same
thing 6 divided by 2 like you said it's
three divided by three like you said
it's a form okay now you know you're
done you know you simplified it or
reduced it to its simplest form when you
get to this point and you look and you
think what's the highest common factor
right the highest gonna have a factor
here is two right between 3 & 4 what's
the highest common factor one I can't
divide anything bigger than one so I'm
done I'm finished three or four is a
simple
so no no you don't so this is what's
going on in my brain that's why I'm
running down so I can explain it to you
but for you guys I'd probably expect you
to go straight to the answer for ones
that are this easy
Oh tell me could be in let's do that 15
over 21 now don't shout out just yet
look at it first let other people have a
think what's the highest common factor
between you lasted like half a second
during 15 and 21 the highest common
factor is now you've got that new head
so you want to divide top and bottom by
3 right divide this one by 3.5 just by
the bottom by 3